indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you
okay we have a um hearing this this
afternoon scheduled for House Bill 428 I
am now opening the public hearing on
House Bill 428
and to begin with uh let me recognize
our Prime sponsor representative Shapiro
I'd also like to acknowledge that
representative lonzer is here filling in
for representative Freda so welcome
representative Lanza
thank you
oh
thank you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and colleagues thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
introduce House Bill 428
for the record I'm representative Joe
Shapiro representing Cheshire 16 which
includes Keen Ward 2 elsta Gilson
Harrisville
Marlboro Marlowe Nelson Stoddard
Sullivan and Roxbury
having served on last year's committee
to study and make recommendations
relative to licensure and Mental Health
Professions this is one bill that came
out of that committee's work
um this bill House Bill 428 was
requested by and written with the
collaboration of the board
of Health mental health practice and
with the collaboration of oplc as well
okay I'm just looking behind me to see
if there's anyone from oplc and I don't
see anybody I recognize
okay good
so
as you will hear in more detail from
others who will testify after me this
bill does three things
it deals with conditional licenses which
to tell you the truth I didn't know
existed until I was on this committee
um
conditional licenses within the board of
mental health practice are
similar to initial licenses that other
states have like Maine and Massachusetts
but New Hampshire never had so for
example
somebody goes to school for a masters of
social work
they come out of school with an MSW
degree
they get a job at a local Community
Mental Health Center they're supervised
by a more experienced clinician
um
prior to conditional licenses that
person was not licensed at all even
though they were providing services to
people under somebody else's name
um
so
in 19 in 2021 a a law was signed into
statute this is already done this is not
what this bill does to create
conditional licenses within the
Board of mental health practice so it
creates conditional licenses for
social workers ba level social workers
associate level social workers
um licensed Mental Health Counselors
and also marriage and family counselors
so you may be asking since they already
created conditional licenses and it's
already in statute why this bill
this bill does three things
number one it requires oplc to set fees
for this these conditional licenses
second it clarifies the statute that was
signed into law in 2021 which creates
conditional licenses
in RSA 330a it adds the relevant
language under licensed independent
Mental Health Counselors and marriage
and family therapists evidently when
they first put this in law
they listed all the different
professions under social work so this is
really just a change not in the language
but where the language goes in the bill
um
the third thing that this does is that
it makes it
clear that those with conditional
licenses are subject to this
jurisdiction of the board so
that is a really important piece because
um
prior to conditional licenses
conditional licenses now exist but they
haven't been implemented they're still
in the rules process
so prior to having these conditional
licenses
I might be right out of Social Work
school and providing services to people
with my services being billed to a
supervisor
but nobody has jurisdiction over me in
terms of consumer protection if I um if
there's an ethical issue if there's an
issue of competence there's no place to
take this too this will clarify that
people these people with conditional
licenses are practicing under the
jurisdiction of the board of Mental
Health
um
I think that's really all I hate to say
it's a housekeeping bill because people
have said that in the past and here and
live to regret it but I think it's a
pretty
um
simple bill that does not do much but it
puts things in their rightful place and
I think hopefully this will expedite
um rules being approved so that this can
actually go into effect
thank you representative questions uh
yes representative Koval
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so does this expand
the uh the potentially expand the
workforce the number of applicants
available to school districts for
example which are having difficulty
right now
hiring and retaining people
does does it does it
add to the the number of of people
available for these positions
I would say
um not really this just clarifies
something that's already in law I would
say that part of the
part of the um
intent of creating various various
levels of licensure
um an associate's level social worker a
ba level social worker and as well as a
master's level social worker part of the
intent going back was to kind of have a
pipeline into the profession which would
incur encourage people to go on and get
further educated and um
become higher level clinicians so I
think if you go back and think of the
whole Gestalt of this Bill yes but this
bill really
um this will not change the numbers it
will just clarify how this is all done
yes representative
um so some of you have been on the
committee
last year know that I've been trying to
reinstate my clinical mental health
counselor license which I let drop in
2015 and I've been jumping through many
Hoops with the board and um
if this bill was passed could they have
granted me a a conditional license two
and a half years ago when I started this
process so that I might have been
working the last two and a half years
I will defer that to somebody else that
would be the case if you were right out
of school I'm not sure since you are
were licensed and then not licensed and
want to be licensed again that might be
a different
um
that might be a different scenario yeah
thank you representative
can I see another hand up uh a moment
ago yes Dr Nagel representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for my
question I just have a question about
the first paragraph
um one where it crosses our board and
puts office of um
professional licensure and certification
why is that change made
that is a good question and I'm going to
defer to the person who's here from
Office of professional life insurance
certification
I don't know if that is now consistent
with other boards or if that is a
um a change just with this board in
terms of who sets the fees
you want to follow up representative
Nagel oh no I'm sorry okay
other questions uh yes
they say a hand up over here
no I guess I didn't okay other questions
okay I guess not thank you very much
you're welcome
did I understand there was someone else
here to testify on this bill did you
yeah we'll need a pink card ma'am
you need to sign up too
speak
Mr chairman while she's feeling filling
that out could I extend welcomes to our
brand newest member and and and note
that we now have a bipartisan baby
caucus in the house and it's really
lovely to see
absolutely absolutely
how do you get it it's a shake yeah
she's two months old her name is she
stay not that I'm upset about it but how
does she stay so quiet well she just ate
so she's satisfied with that and a new
diaper and so hopefully fingers crossed
okay
not an answer we want to note an answer
we want to
get along so
and Mr chairman I I also want to just
comment that I heard the the most
wonderful rendition of the national
anthem this morning from
oh yeah Christina
good job
[Applause]
okay well thank you for completing that
and uh
please proceed a few minutes please sure
thank you honorable committee members my
name is Elizabeth Eaton I am an attorney
over at oplc and I'm here representing
the board of mental health
um
I have testimony from
the former chair of the board of mental
health and unfortunately I don't have
the printouts with me and I apologize
for that I can certainly follow up and
send that over but I can read it today
if that's acceptable and then I can also
answer your questions about oplc
generally and after you read it if you
could just submit it the
clerk yes or if you want to summarize
you can just give them your written copy
too sure I can do that so
um
HP 428 has been proposed to clarify an
add-on amendment to HB 143 which took
effect in October 2021
that bill created conditional licenses
for clinical social workers
clinical Mental Health Counselors and
marriage and family therapists
unfortunately the bill was added to
three RSA 330a 18 which is the section
of RSA 330 that describes the various
requirements for licensure as a social
worker
the conditional license section was was
added as RSA 330a 18d Social Work
conditional license
the problem with the legislation in HP
143 was that section e of RSA 330a 8 18d
describes the requirements for
conditional licensure as a clinical
mental health counselor and section F
describes the requirements for
conditional licensure as a marriage and
family therapist as noted above the
title of RSA 330a 18 is social work
conditional license
the board of mental health practice
which Dr Goodnow was member of from 2016
through 2022 endorses House Bill 428
because it rectifies the misplacement of
enf
and moves them to where they logically
belong
hb428 moves section e to RSA 330a19
which details the requirements for
clinical Mental Health Counselors
and moves F to RSA 330a 21 which details
the requirements for marriage and family
therapists
this legislation if passed will smooth
the ability of the board of mental
health practice to write logical
administrative rules
together
hb428 and the rules revision revisions
to follow will make it easier for
applicants and the public to follow the
law
it was a little bit dry his testimony
but that's the logic behind this
amendment here
I can take questions now if you'd want
okay thank you representative Weber
and if you know is is the reason that
we've gone from board to oplsc because
there there have been a series of
reorganizations and various pieces of
the administrative work have been
transferred from boards to the oplc over
the years and it's now conforming the
statute to the current practice
correct under
um I believe it's under 330 or 310 a
a and I'm not sure of that exact statute
reference the oplc now has authority
over all fee
um setting and so fees now fall under
the oplc
as part of a regulatory scheme
thank you you're welcome other questions
I see none
okay thank you very much
thank you
is there anyone else here to testify on
House Bill 428
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 428
and we are going to go into executive
session on the bills that we have
noticed in the calendar
not for another 12. oh I'm sorry thanks
for pointing that out we'll take a brief
recess and then we'll be going into
executive session at 1 30. thank you
thank you
foreign
is 130 we are going to reconvene and go
into an executive session
I would like to point out that after
discussion with various committee
members I am going to continue the
following bills
House Bill 587
I'll spill 598.
house bill 264.
House Bill 574
House Bill 282 and House Bill 397 and
these will be noticed in the calendar
for the
based on a continuance
and we do so so that anyone who is his
explicitly for those bills uh you know
may make other arrangements on the
schedule yes Mr chairman point of order
yes so the other ones that you do not
list are not going to be exact today
those are the ones that are if you
listed the ones that are not those are
going to be continued represented
continued yes so the others will be
addressed today okay
yes representative Nagel
I'm sorry I'm sorry get my glasses on
I'm sorry sorry it wasn't a quick enough
study to tick off the ones we're not
exacting today would you be so kind as
to repeat that list oh sure
uh House Bill 587
oh it's Bill 598
house bill 264.
House Bill 574
House Bill 282
and house bill 397.
anyone else need me to repeat or
thank you
yes representative Weber
really question of procedure I
understand there are issues with those
bills in a normal in a more normal year
uh we would have subcommittees on those
bills and I'm hoping that
uh in established in proportion roughly
to our committee makeup if there are
concerns with those bills I hope that
that a small number of us might
be able to work together on whatever
needs to happen on them just so that
it's not a blind side when we come back
because a lot of those bills didn't have
any problems as of the end of business
they always welcome input uh all those
early bills representative Leon
um yes these the bills that were noticed
today were all of the early bills that
had been heard prior to today so that
they were available should the committee
be ready to have an executive session
because we weren't sure heading into the
hearings yesterday what would be
available to us and unlike last year we
can't notice for any bills that have
been heard maybe available in executive
session so it's a matter of figuring out
exactly how these are noticed
appropriately to make sure the committee
can do our business while also not
rushing anything that that needs to
maybe be heard next week we've noticed
executive sessions for both Wednesday
and Thursday afternoons so we will have
adequate time to discuss them further
representative Merchant if I could
follow up on representative Weber's
comment
on these bills that we're going to pass
on today
to help the committee going forward
is there any thought of what you thought
is Mr chairman about having a small
group of us get together
to brainstorm the pros and cons of the
bill so we can go back with some sort of
a recommendation to the school committee
correct you're talking about the six
bills we've decided to continue at least
ask them at correct an ad hoc committee
at least so we can at least have some
discussion about the pros and cons of
the bill versus the subcommittee itself
representative I mean representative
land did you have a comment on that uh
thank you I I think this was more of a
scheduling issue as opposed to there
being large issues around them we heard
these bills yesterday so some of them we
just need to we just need a little bit
more time for everybody to read through
them before before we're able to see if
it's time to have an executive session
and um I'm not I think it might be a
little premature to pull together a
subcommittee uh perhaps we might
consider that Wednesday when we meet
again
the issue with the subcommittee is these
are first committee bills and a
subcommittee once appointed has to be
noticed in the calendar before it can
meet we did
for the last two years have some very
informal groups that were less than a
quorum made up of people who were
interested in a particular Bill who just
got together informally and talked about
the bills because
they had a mutual interest and it was
not formal it was not directed by
anybody it was just a clump of people
that came together but we can't talk
about our concerns here now unless we
open we could if we have actually opened
an executive session and then recessed
it again but I don't think anybody wants
to do that and we don't have time to do
an actual subcommittee because as soon
as the chair notices appoints a
subcommittee with official duties to
recommend on a bill then that has to go
into the calendar and I don't think
we've got time to get it in the calendar
and get it done
going forward representative land on the
early one thank you for pointing out my
error and wording I met more of these ad
hoc groups to figure out next week as
we're meeting or as we can reach out to
each other as well if somebody has a
concern and they know that somebody else
is involved there's nothing prohibiting
less than a quorum discussing what the
issues may be that's how that's how we
generally tend to arrive at decisions I
believe outside of
representative Weber no I'm good okay
all right
um so those bills being continued let us
proceed with the ones we still want to
consider those of you who are in session
this morning
um heard me announce that we will be
considering HP 47 today along with the
other bills that I noticed so let us
begin with HB 47 and I'd like to back up
excuse me
oh as if we decided we're going to do
that oh okay my apologies
um okay uh forget I said that
uh let's uh proceed to consideration of
HB 428 then do I have a motion
representative Shapiro do you want to
make a motion on 428 it was your bill
that we just heard
no it was so um it was announced as we
just heard it
so so we are able to consider it where
we just heard it and we're okay I'm
gonna execut immediately following the
hearing we are able to do that okay yes
thank you for explaining I would like to
move that we
um
vote ought to pass on House Bill 428.
I'd like
discussion
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Shapiro
would you like to speak to it further
I just think that it's a um Common Sense
bill that will clarify something that's
that's a policy that's already put in
been put in place and that we will be
um
helping the board of mental health
practice and oplc move ahead with
conditional licenses which I think are
of value to the state especially in
terms of consumer protection
okay any any other discussion on this
motion
a representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman
looking at this because this is just a
very clear cleanup I was recently
appointed to the Joint legislative
administrative rules committee and that
is one of the things that we are working
on there is moving from fines being done
at the board level and being brought to
oplc so this is a good streamlining
process and thank you representative
Shapiro for bringing this to us
yes representative
I agree that it's a good bill to pass
cleaning up language and moving
requirements from social workers and
mental health counselors in the right
places where they should be because
people might not think it's all the same
but it's not all the same little
specifics so it sounds I'm going to vote
for it thank you okay thank you
of the discussion
okay seeing none I will ask the clerk to
call a roll
okay this is my first time through the
list so if I don't pronounce your name
right let me know
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative King Bill King uh yes
representative kofol
yes
representative McLean
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov pelosov yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
definitely yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative telez
Thomas yes yes
Tay is
did I get that righteous
and representative lonza
yes
and the chair and finally representative
McDonald yes
20-0
there's no objection I'd like to put
this on the consent calendar any
objection to that nope okay
we will so note it
by no consent
um Vice chairman can put it on the Green
Sheet here okay
uh yes would you write the committee
report representative Shapiro yes for
the calendar yes okay thank you very
much
okay moving on is is it now appropriate
to go to hb47 ladies
um I'd rely very heavily clearly on the
vice chairman and also on the ranking
member so I thank both ladies for their
assistance
um hb47 again I mentioned that this
morning on the house floor we are going
to consider that today also and I would
like to represent yeah represent
recognize representative Nagel promotion
I'd like to make a motion to make this
bill an expedient to legislate
okay representative Seth King do you
have a motion I'd like to second that
motion hey representative Nagel do you
wish to speak to your motion yes please
um and Mr chairman could we all please
be reminded exactly what the bill is
because we came without that on our list
of papers for today it's a relative go
ahead representative uh this bill was
about organ donation and it created
um
I don't have it let me grab it it's at
the end
Seattle stations for organ donors by the
doctors what it required was that those
performing Advanced Trauma Life Support
follow a specific protocol in
anticipation of Oregon donation that the
billwood that's house or the document
would have to subsequently be signed by
the physician of record into additional
nurses
go ahead okay yes
um we received the intent of a lot of
these bills is is Honorable
um there is a problem with organ
donation and there's a variety of
strategies to try to improve that the
concern is that this bill
would actually do quite the opposite and
more concerning would put trauma
patients at harm
um we received compelling testimony from
people that perform trauma Services
um that their primary responsibility is
to save the life of the trauma patient
we also learned and from my personal
experience that the trauma team is
frequently quite variable when I
performed trauma in Alaska it was me
it can also consist of a university
setting of multiple individuals and
because of that trauma protocols can be
quite variable we also learned that
there is no such thing as a trauma
protocol that it's actually a set of
guidelines unlike cardiac life support
trauma's uh it's a moving Target and
frequently you you can't follow a
specific
um guide you have to fly by the seat of
your pants frequently and by giving a
group of individuals a recognized
protocol that they must follow and then
later document that they did follow that
protocol you start to put the risk of
that trauma patient the life of that
trauma patient at risk
indirectly that will affect the ability
of the um the organs to be available for
donation we also learned that trauma is
not a great source of donated organs
primarily because of the procedures that
have to be done and so on and so forth
so in the end the concern was that we
would be putting people's lives at risk
the trauma docs also informed us number
one is that they wouldn't sign such a
form because they would not they
considered insulting that was the word
that several of them used they would not
put their name on such a document they
also said that they didn't think that it
was appropriate to have nurses who would
be unqualified in these documents or
these protocols or guidelines would be
signing such a forms and we also heard
from nursing groups that said the same
thing
thank you
other uh questions or discussion on this
motion
yes representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chair I would also support
um
an itl for this bill
it seems to imply that in some cases
that people who are dealing with a
serious trauma did not really try to
save the life of the patient because
they're interested in the or more
interested in the organs than the life
of the patient
and not only do I personally find that
suspect but I don't think we should ever
be making
um laws based on one anecdote which
people seem to bring
um
so I think it lacked any kind of data to
back up the reasoning for making such a
law
thank you
of the discussion
seeing none I'll ask Clark to call the
wall
representative land yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov
yes
representative Weber
representative McKay
representative
Canon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative
tayas
yes
representative Lanza yes and
representative McDonald yes
it's unanimous 20-0
okay thank you again if there's no
objections this will go on the consent
calendar
moving on to
hb91-5n-a relative to privacy
obligations of the Department of Health
and Human Services
representative Leon I believe there's an
amendment 142h
yes thank you Mr chairman I would like
to move amendment 142-h that was handed
out the other day in session I'm not
sure if everybody still has their copies
this is the one where it clarify sorry I
need a second before I speak I apologize
is there a second to the motion
representative McLean seconds
may I speak to that yes representative
thank you all proceed uh now uh so that
Amendment clarified the job titles and
the classifications within the uh within
the bill because they had been
classified incorrectly in the original
drafting so this is uh one of those
cleanup amendments that hopefully um it
still keeps with the same intent of the
bill and just clarifies that language
and and for clarity Mr chair could I ask
for the number of the amendment again
yes that's one fort it's a 2023 hyphen
142h
142h yes
thank you
point of order Mr chair uh yes
representative profile so I understand
there may be some people in the room who
are here for the exact session on some
of the bills that were continued
including House Bill 587 and so I just
wanted to clarify for anybody present
who is who's here for that bill or some
of the others that were continued that
we will not be hearing those today or
not be executing those today yes exactly
and that's that's why I I had announced
that earlier
oh it did perhaps some of these folks
joined us I believe that is the case oh
thank you sir
okay I can run through the list again if
anyone wants me to
I think we should okay yeah
okay again the bills that will be
continued
uh will be uh in other words we will not
take be taking them up today will be HB
587 HB 598 HB 264 HB 574 HB 282 and HB
397.
if you're here for to who will observe
the disposition of those bills they will
not be heard today thank you
thank you
okay further discussion on Amendment
142h we got related to house bill 91.
is there any other discussion on this
amendment
zero one four two eight it was blue
what
it's the amendment relative to uh
yes um would you like me to read through
what's in this amendment so that
everybody knows so the first section to
amend the bill says it amends the what's
inserted in section two of the bill and
it replaces paragraph three what that
does is it changes the year from 2023 to
2024.
because implementation wise there's no
way that this would happen
um by 2023 that was just a drafting
error left over from the prior version
then the next section amends section
three of the bill and what that does is
it says that it does the classifications
it says that the classification shall be
Information Technology manager 4 labor
grade 3 step 7. that's in section three
and then in section four it also
restates those funding to Information
Technology manager four positions as
required in paragraph three of this
section
so those were ones that had the wrong
labor grade and it was referring to a
prior year we all know it was a little
bit difficult and everybody was working
really really hard to make sure that
everything got out of Olsson there were
a few things where we had where we had
some small things that will be cleaned
up in amendments not just on this bill
but I'm sure on plenty others this
session
okay any other discussion on the
amendment
representative I'm being told that
there are people who didn't get the copy
of the amendment so
okay that would be helpful we'll get
some copies and
is this the amendment that was handed
out right by representative Edwards
right at the time that he was presenting
the bill went to OLS came right back and
then he was Distributing it okay I know
I have I'll be honest I don't have mine
right in front of me either but I do
remember him walking around putting him
in front of each of us
yeah I believe
a lot of papers have been flying around
this world in the last couple of weeks
and with more to come so
it's not a blizzard outside there's been
a blizzard inside not nearly as cold in
here though but
yeah just give us a moment we'll get
copies for everyone
that came in and said why don't we just
buy everybody
at least
Mr chairman okay
okay Mr chairman yes could I make a
request that you also read to us the
list of what we will be hearing sure
what we will be voting on yeah
okay uh obviously 91 I will be voting on
the bill itself after we dispose of the
amendment
and then we will be voting on uh House
Bill 329
house bill 566.
House Bill 565
in house bill 580.
thank you sir
well we just did that
let me just do that
yep never mind okay don't do that to me
I got it
okay does everyone have a copy now
give everybody a chance to look it over
everybody all set or do you need more
time
I'm sensing you're all set
any other discussion on this amendment
if there is none I will ask the clerk to
call the roll
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative cofult
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
represented in Missouri yes
representative Nagel
yes
representative peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Tellez yes
representative Lanza yes
and representative McDonald yes
20-0
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to move ought to pass
as amended by Amendment
142h on House Bill 91.
okay is there a second to that motion
second representative McLean seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
I'm representative Palmer I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman this bill
establish is not about security it is
about privacy those are two separate
issues and I believe there's a bill in
another committee that is dealing with a
security apparatus within the state
within the Department of Health and
Human Services and more broadly in the
state with our computer systems and uh
and how those are secured you can have
something that's secured but not private
so it might be secure in there but all
of your information and data is flying
around for anybody to be able to access
so long as they can get into that secure
body what this bill does is it creates a
privacy Council in order to make sure
that the Department of Health and Human
Services is taking the same proactive
steps to protect personally identifiable
information as is done in the private
sector by having two jobs added that are
information so that our information
technology managers we will be able to
bring in experts that understand the
needs of privacy and know how to
structure these coming in from hopefully
from
no recruit from the best and figure out
where whoever they're able to get to
come in and just make sure that they are
looking to privacy and making sure that
our information is kept as private as
possible this is something that goes
along with article 2B in our
constitution there will be public facing
minutes from them I know that in and
it's it's something where they're going
to be trying to make sure that we're not
exposing the incredibly personal
information that is kept at the
department for a surprising number of
people to vulnerabilities
thank you of the discussion
Mr chair yes I'd like to speak in
opposition to this Bill yes thank you
this bill will cost taxpayers three
hundred thousand dollars annually no
evidence was provided that the current
DHHS security Protocols are lacking or
that user data has been or currently is
being breached furthermore the greatest
threats to privacy come from large
corporate or state actors as is common
practice the Security Professionals
would likely store patient data on
third-party corporate servers and use
software programs that are closed source
non-free and proprietary and therefore
would be inherently untrustworthy thank
you thank you
of the discussion
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
I also oppose the bill for slightly
different reasons one is
why a legislative body has to tell an
executive branch to do something they
should be doing anyways
that's the first thing number two why
this is strictly in one agency versus
Statewide
the issue of privacy should be Statewide
not strictly looking at it from a
particular agency
and three we do already have oversight
of DHHS and that oversight committee can
hold them accountable
to achieve what we're trying to do
without this law so therefore I oppose
it okay thank you representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and I'm going to
vote for this bill
because I see it as being first of all
the largest executive department that
holds the most personal of data of ours
um so I privacy is a real concern there
uh it's the bill we have in front of us
and it's a good first step and an
example for how to do it elsewhere if we
decide we need to do it elsewhere
um we tell executive departments what to
do all the time because we make the laws
so I don't have a problem with that one
but and the reason that I think that
I'm comfortable going ahead with it is
it is something that I think we thought
thought to be doing and they aren't so
we said that let's make it a little more
clear what the expectations are so for
that reason I am going to vote in favor
of this I didn't vote for it last time
because there were issues of
interrelationships between
privacy and accessibility for uh the
people who were using the system but
this is just a board a freestanding
board so I'm going to vote in favor of
it
okay another discussion
representative go to call are we allowed
to ask questions of each other
relative to what we've just said sure
um can I ask you a question of
Representative King
what you said was really powerful
um and I'm I'm curious you said that the
Privacy data that that
these private companies would access in
creating this this um platform they
could have access to and and use for
their own purposes could you
explain that further what's the risk of
that what's the likelihood of that I
just want to
so um
lots of times
um organizations they don't
um run their own servers on their own
private Hardware they contract out for
to AWS Amazon
and we know from
history recent history it's well known
that third party corporate servers work
at the behest of intelligence agencies
they can be infiltrated from people that
don't necessarily have security
clearance and that data often is and can
be sold to bidders around the world
including the Chinese the Russians so
that is a serious problem and I
understand that my ideal world where we
store all of our own data and we use
only open source free and open source
software that's not going to happen
tomorrow but what I have a problem with
with this bill is that we're spending
three hundred thousand dollars I asked
the people giving the testimony if they
had any evidence that data has been
recently or is being breached there was
no answer given and furthermore I think
that the security protocols that these
professionals are going to use is
basically just a waste of money because
at the end of the day this data is going
to be stored on corporate servers that I
personally do not trust and I think
if you if you if you if you have a
security I I'm a techie geek I have a
background in these things and if you
understand just how uh vulnerable all of
our data is on just about everything
um you would see this as just a total
waste of money personally so
another discussion
representative Palmer
I just have a maybe I need to be
clarified I'm not arguing about the
money part but this is
it doesn't say in here that they're
going to be hiring outside companies to
do this it's it's extra employees within
the
HHS to work with this board on increased
security so I don't I don't I don't I'm
not seeing how this is going to be
additional new software that would have
any more I mean it would be the whatever
HHS is using I would think so that any
vulnerability would would be there
either way but hopefully this would be
leading to better monitoring of the
software that we do have or that they
are using
that's just the way I'm looking at it I
presented Leon
um thank you Mr chairman um I think
representative Seth King is worried that
we're putting a big a large set of bars
and padlocks on the front door by
leaving a screen door on the back with
vulnerabilities with the system
um that that is an issue that I think
goes a lot broader than this bill and
there's a bill House Bill 519 that is
relative to establishing a chief
information security officer for the
Department of Information Technology I
think that making note of this
vulnerability and that you can't have
privacy without security is something
that is worth mentioning and is worth
bringing forward because if it's not
secure it won't be private but
fortunately I think that that issue is
there's there's large there's a lot a
larger effort to address that in House
Bill 519 this one's securing the front
door from people getting to your
information on privacy and that one's
securing the back door I do think that
they're a pair and it's important to
it's important to secure both and I
think that it's a very valid point but I
believe that this bill furthers securing
that front door in the privacy and
that's why I'm supporting this board
that could be one of the recommendations
that comes from this board as well so I
think that this is a good step even if
it is not complete
other yes representative Weber
do we know what committee fives the
other bill is 519
she's looking it up
it's an executive departments and
administration yeah I thought we didn't
have that one
representative Merchant given thank you
Mr chair but given the fact that it's
come to my attention on House Bill 519
we're looking what I think appears to be
the possibility redundancy between this
bill and 519.
and if that's the case I'd like to again
either retain this bill to find out
what's going on with 519 to be sure
we're not building redundancy into two
requests at one
through
Edna is going One Direction we're going
another Direction Where We could do one
or the other and not both
I don't have enough information about
519 to move forward on it
okay representative Leon uh
yes so I would point out that this this
bill is not strictly speaking a security
bill this is a privacy and security Bill
and there are great many things
um
and those topics often often are
discussed hand in hand but in practice
they're
there are very they're they're different
topics and
um information privacy often involves
um
it needs security as representative Leon
has pointed out but it also involves
human factors it involves training it
involves awareness it involves policies
and so I think that this is this goes
far beyond security I think it's a step
in the right direction having having
heard an earlier uh an earlier version
of this in the last biennium I think
that this this bill's time has come I
think it is much improved it's a step in
the right direction and I I would
support the uh the motion thank you of
the discussion
representative Weber do you have your
hand up or
thank you sorry I I was also trying to
pull up the text to the bill at the same
time uh
I just want to remind people what this
bill actually does
it creates
a governance board within the Department
of Health and Human Services
but all of the people
that are in there are either in the
department itself or provide services to
the department so what you're doing
is
bringing all the people who might have
pieces of the puzzle when as it relates
to privacy together
at one time for once a month or once a
quarter or whenever it convenes
and making sure that they're talking to
each other
and yes we have some support in there
for that board because it's large and
it's got a lot of work to do
but I see that for me the coming
together of a bunch of people to to try
and solve problems that we think we're
all agreed or really concerning problems
is not a bad thing to do and although
there are the larger issues of security
and how that's handled and how the data
is handled it's really not what this
bill is about except insofar as these
people might recommend that the data be
handled differently
anyway so that I just wanted to be sure
that we were all focused on what this
bill actually does it doesn't mandate
where the data is going or what's
happening with it it's creating
as you will another layer of oversight
of the discussion
okay I see no other discussion
with that I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll again the motion is ought to pass
is amended on House Bill 91.
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofault yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
yes
representative peloso yes
representative Weber
representative McKay
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Tellez
yes
representative representative Lanza yes
and representative McDonald yes
18-2
okay and uh
it's my understanding that might be a
Minority Report on this representative
king or
yes I'm happy to provide the Minority
Report so this will go on the regular
calendar then
are you not willing
he has to be willing as well there can't
be a Minority Report if it goes on
consent
we never have minority reports on
consent so if there's a Minority Report
it needs to go on the regular calendar
okay
but okay can it go on uh yes can you go
on consent calendar with two two no's
it can go on the Quezon calendar with
two no's if both of the people who voted
no agree to it and if neither one of
them wants to write a Minority Report
but representative King has said that he
wants to write a Minority Report and if
there is a Minority Report it can't go
on consent because it has to go on the
regular calendar because it has a
Minority Report
thank you I just didn't hear both of the
representatives being asked if they were
willing for it to go on the consent
calendar well one of them that's because
one of them had already stated he wanted
to write a Minority Report which
precludes it going unconsent under any
circumstances
thank you
any other questions on this
all right
moving on to House Bill 329 Mr chairman
yes
for my Records who made the motion to
ought to pass as amended
and who was the one that made the second
bomber
thank you representative Leon moved and
representative Palmer second thank you
okay
all right moving on to House Bill 329
representative Murphy yes I would like
to make a motion that we retain house
bill 329.
and is there a second to that second
representative Nagel seconds
representative Murphy would you like to
speak to your motion yes please thank
you
um
briefly speaking I think that we can all
recognize and agree that you know
medical Registries have been of
significant benefit to
you know many many people including
probably many of us in this room
um so I don't think it's in dispute that
a registry for ALS patients which suffer
a very devastating disease is
inappropriate in any way shape or form
to discover
etiologies treatments and ultimately how
we can cure that disease uh when we
first drafted the I was approached by Dr
Elijah stomal who you met last week
a neurologist at Dartmouth who has been
doing a tremendous amount of work for
many years with ALS patients
he asked me to put a registry forward in
in doing so and with the the strong work
of
um Attorney John Williams we were able
to come up with a initial attempt at a
registry bill that you saw last week the
bill had with it obviously a significant
fiscal note which is tied obviously to
the oversight of HHS
um in doing so and that's not that's not
inconsistent with other registries in
the in the state whereby they um for can
we have multiple cancer Registries we
have infectious disease Registries we
have a lot of colorectal Registries
colonoscopy Registries and they have
contractual relationships oftentimes
with HHS
um what we have attempted to do to Pivot
away from having this under the auspices
Control Authority
um to establish and then run a registry
at HHS with crafted another a bill an
amended bill which is essentially ready
to go
but what it also assumes uh is that
number one there will be no HHS
involvement therefore there will be no
fiscal note attached to it
um so there'll be absolutely no cost to
the state in a sense they'll be
reporting to HHS but the registry would
be housed established in operationally
administered to uh at Dartmouth
Hitchcock we're essentially 99 of all
the ALS patients go
from the state currently so this would
establish a registry it would also
maintain a mandatory reporting by
physicians and providers that diagnose
these patients it will be free from the
oversight of HHS and the only reason and
one of the reasons that I'm asking to
retain it at this point is in order to
shift the oversight and establishment of
this registry to Dartmouth Health we
need to clear the hurdles with legal
with I.T with some educational documents
who will administer the data how will
the data be collected how will we get
the data from outside you know
Physicians who are not DH related so
there's a number of small I wouldn't say
small but a number of issues which are
surmountable but we could not actually
get done within the past week so what we
have done is draft a a subsequent bill
that will basically put the registry in
the hands of Dartmouth health and once
we clear the hurdles that I just
mentioned I will bring it back in the
fall if that is the wish of the
committee so that's where we stand right
now thank you okay another discussion
motion to retain
I was Bill 329.
seeing no other discussion
I'll ask the Clarks Colorado
I think
it's a representative representative
Nagel second did it thank you
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes it is representative Bill
King yes
representative kofo
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel yes
representative peloso yes
representative Weber
representative McKay
representative Cannon
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
representative Merchant a point of order
if I may I want to be sure it was okay
unfortunately I stepped out of the room
for a second before I came back in so I
don't know if I can actually vote I
think I can but were you here yes yes
what yes okay thank you yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Tellez
okay I'll get it
thank you yes
representative Lanza yes and
representative McDonald yes
and it's 20 to zero
and this does not need to go on the
consent calendar or any other calendar
as I understand it representative Weber
it stays
motions to with retain stay right in the
committee and we act on them late
October early November and then the
house acts on them early in January
okay thank you
okay next up is House Bill 566. uh
representative McLean do you have an
emotion
yeah thank you Mr I move itl on this
bill
okay is there a second
I'd like to Second representative mazur
seconds
representative McLean do you want to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair
um I I think uh the problem that this
bill tries to address is real
um and I have a lot of Sympathy for the
folks bringing this forward and and
that's why we have a special committee
trying to address this issue but if you
look at the the financials that are in
the Bill versus the the mountain that it
has to go over we heard testimony that
in Vermont uh they're making six
thousand dollars more a year
in Maine 8 000 and in Massachusetts 10
000 more a year what this bill does
after it gets through excuse me just a
second everybody knows it's the child
care bill right I know there was some
confusion earlier what bills were up so
I'm sorry go ahead so I'm sorry so
um so what the way that this bill would
work is it would give retention bonuses
when you come on board and then at three
years and then at five years and then
every five years after that so basically
you're looking at three thousand dollars
a retention bonus every five years
if you look at Massachusetts where
you're making ten thousand dollars a
year more and that say same five year
period That's fifty thousand dollars
versus three thousand dollars so I think
we're going to be putting money that you
know we're gonna need and I don't think
this is going to achieve what it's going
to do three thousand dollars is not
going to shift the needle versus fifty
thousand dollars so
um uh I I would uh prefer to wait to see
what comes out of the special committee
and I would uh be looking to it all this
Bill thank you Mr chair
another discussion yes representative
Shapiro
I will vote to support this bill
um I agree with some of the things that
were said that it's a lot of money that
it will not solve the problem in itself
um
I was taken with some of the people who
testified with who talked about this
sending a strong message to people who
are working in daycare who owners who
are hemorrhaging employees that um that
the state cares about this situation and
that they're looking to do something I
think this is just a small part of the
puzzle but I think it's a part of the
puzzle nevertheless and I think we
should concentrate on the policy of
helping the workforce and in in daycare
and let the finance committee deal with
the amounts of money that it um
that it needs
thank you representative Shapiro
representative Weber
and just to elaborate a little bit for
myself on what representative Shapiro
just said I I do agree with some of the
concerns that you have uh but
procedurally uh if we send this to the
bill to the floor as an itl
we have effectively
foreclosed this option for ourselves not
only for this year but for next year as
well
because it can't come back
and so I too would urge that we do one
of two things either
pass this bill on the policy and send it
to finance where they can put it in the
pot with all of the other
things that they're considering or that
perhaps we retain it in committee so so
that we can see where people are going
and and use it next year to work on more
if if we need to uh rather than killing
it outright so I am certainly opposing
the itl
um I I could be persuaded either way on
the other two motions but my preference
would be to pass and send it to finance
but I'm concerned about it
dying completely either here on the
floor so a retained motion would also be
I think perfectly appropriate thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr
thank you I want to follow with
representative Weber
what I'm concerned about if we do an itl
and gets to the floor
and it passes with itl then we also have
indefinite postponement that we really
get ourselves into a situation where we
can't take up something comfortable
because the topic itself has been killed
and we don't know what's going to come
out of the commission so I do support
what you're saying as far as retaining
the bill
and that way there we can wait for the
commission to do its work and find out
if in fact the commission decides that
something like this isn't in play and
the topic is Germaine then next year we
can take up the bill again and modify it
through amendments but if we itl it it
goes to the house again and it gets
indefinite postponement we're really
sunk
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman
um I I think that while we're looking at
these dollar figures we're also looking
at the policy of subsidizing a private
industry and having these subsidies to
go to offset wages
that is actually a pretty chilling
precedent because once you get the
government involved in paying part of
the wages you're moving to this
public-private partnership that before
has been called things like fascism when
you have the government and private
business to intertwined things get very
very dangerous when we look at this bill
in the policy
the question would be how much should
the state pay should all these child
care workers be employees I don't think
anybody in the state would say that they
should be state employees I think that
there are many many other avenues
available for the special committee on
child care to look at but I don't think
that subsidies are the New Hampshire way
subsidies in order to supplement wages
it this is exactly what got us into the
inflationary environment that we are in
today when you look at these subsidies
that has raised the price of everything
in order to provide the services the
companies need to rate the prices as
they raise the prices then it gets
harder for everybody those who have a
pot of money that they can access
especially if it's not their own are
able to supplement it and those who are
left on the margins like our child care
workers and the families paying for it
are then left bearing the brunt of
inflation from the government trying to
do good we've heard these families
already or at least the federal
government has hurt these families
already by the all the checks that were
sent out during covid to try and
supplement the losses that economic
policy has come home to roost in this
inflation and in what is making Child
Care unaffordable for families in New
Hampshire this bill only doubles down on
those failed policies and I believe that
it should be in should be voted and
expedient to legislate and should get to
the floor
yes representative
um part of the testimony we heard was
that the that governor sununu was
looking towards public-private
Partnerships for this particular issue
and so for that reason I'd at least like
to retain the bill so we can see where
the commission comes and what the
governor wants to do rather than having
us kill it
representative Shapiro
yes I I would take exception to
um equating this bill with fascism
um for one and I would say that we only
have to look towards how we you know who
we call when our house is on fire we
call the fire department and that is
publicly supported
um in in retirement we are supported in
part
um for some of us in total for many of
us by Medicare our public schools are
paid for not enough but in part by the
total State and I think that um you know
you may I understand that that some
people would disagree that this is going
to be effective but I think personally
that may be the case but it's not
because we're
um introducing the state into a service
that is necessary for individual people
for families and for the state economy I
mean I think we heard over and over
again that this is not a system that so
far has responded to the market
you can't just keep raising
um
tuition for people
in order to get enough money to pay
people a living wage it's there's it's
broken it doesn't work there needs to be
something else introduced so
I would take exception to the fact that
introducing
Public Funding into this system
um is um
to be equated with fascism in some way
of the discussion
by representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and I apologize if that was
taken as saying that this bill is
fascism I was taking it to a possible
conclusion of it being fully State fully
subsidizing the the the income of those
child care providers but this would be a
step towards that intertwining our fire
departments participate in the state
retirement system which is a choice that
was made for these public so while I
while I see that there are some of these
points where we do have entanglement I
think that this is pretty far outside
those other ones but I'll in the
interest of getting along I'll back off
from that and we can continue with some
of these other policy points I know this
has been a great committee working
together and I don't want to rub on any
of the source slots that anybody has
of the discussion oh yes representative
kofault
um yes so Milton Friedman famously uh
created a four quadrant grid
um on the top I believe it says who's
paying for it and on the side it says
who are they who are they buying it for
and um you know if if you're if you're
spending your own money on something you
want you're gonna you're gonna shop
value you're gonna get your money's
worth
um I I think that if we are
subsidizing system if we're turning
daycare into a publicly funded entity uh
it's going to go the way a lot of these
things go which is
um we're spending other people's money
on something for other people and that
is actually the lowest the lowest value
quadrant in Milton Friedman's equation
so I I think this is
um
the wrong solution to to a problem that
does need to be fixed and I think that
it's it's one that will be a slippery
slope if we start to go down this road
um there we will end up going further
down this road and I think creating a
lot of unintended consequences
representative Merchant
foreign
wasn't per se in this
bill but came up in the testimony
many
businesses that want to do Child Care
struggle with startup cost and we have a
small business administration one of the
things I did hear about was maybe trying
to help them get it
business up and running which is giving
the money to the employees themselves
I would like to retain this bill and
work on those kind of options and saying
how do we build into the system
more child care opportunities because if
we don't have child care what I heard
was that an increase with women
participation rates of 1.3 percent to
the economy of the states a billion
dollars
so I think there's enough incentive here
to find a way to work our way through it
but we can't get there if we don't
retain the bill and begin to think about
various options so the policy of trying
to find a way to increase more access
to increase our economy and help those
get involved with the economy through
Workforce which is a problem
therefore I really would like to have us
retain the bill
for two reasons one work on it but more
importantly listen to the governor's
Commission in saying what's coming out
of that one as well and give us some
time to hear all that we need to hear to
make it work
thank you representative Cannon
I have to agree with representative
Merchant
um
it's a challenge that I've I've seen
where families want to go to work but
they have kids that need to be taken
care of and the businesses they're going
into don't have child care
there so they're somewhat dependent on
trying to find other sources for child
care the child care organizations have
the problem is they it's that trying to
find employees to provide that child
care is expensive
and they have trouble trying to bind
people to to take those jobs so there's
a couple of catch-22s here it's round
and round and round so I I would like I
I too would like to retain the bill
because it's something is needed uh and
to try and figure out
um do we give money to the just to the
child care organizations or do we find a
way to
encourage organizations to to put child
care as a part of those those
organizations and how do we do that do
we give them some sort of break or or
whatever it's got there's got to be a
way to do that if you want to get your
employees on board you need to help find
them child care for their their kids
thank you
yes representative Palazzo
thank you Mr chair I agree with the
representative land that it's not a
problem for government to fund this and
I support the itl so two points first uh
I think this industry is in a perfect
spot to self-regulate
one of concerns that they cannot pay
more because otherwise
they would lose clients but we heard
testimonies one place has 80 people
waiting list and another place had 87
people waiting list it's a perfect spot
to pay
a child care workers more and the second
concern was that we cannot charge
parents more but if we look into our
Public Schools it's what's happening in
my sit here is that so now it's like
they spent like 20
000 a year per pupil and what does it
mean it means that parents pay more in
taxes so when you say that parents
cannot pay more let's let's subsidize it
it just means that they will be paying
more in taxes thank you thank you
yes representative
in my ideal world it would be fantastic
if we got back to the point where we
were just a few decades ago where
one income could fully support an entire
family and Mom could stay home and raise
her kids
or down in that case that matter of fact
my father spent more time at home with
me and my mom worked away
um but that's my Ideal World
when we increase everybody's taxes to
pay for child care what and among other
things what we're doing is we're now
we're making it less financially viable
for one parent to stay home and raise
the child especially when the costs of
sending them off to daycare have been
subsidized by the government
and so now what we I mean there's so so
many problems I know we're not going to
get to my ideal solution tomorrow but
this is just another nail in the coffin
of making it less possible and
incentivizing making it less possible to
stay home and raise your children making
it more financially a requirement to
send them to daycare and furthermore
um I often had to go to a nanny when I
was a kid I went to a lady who
um she was a stay-at-home mom and she
would have two or three kids that she
would raise or help raise during the
daytime this was not a huge source of
income for her it was just a little bit
of money on the side but we had amazing
care and when we in in when we
turn it into an industry now we're
sending our children off to corporate
okay a court a business a real business
a corporate model of daycare as opposed
to just the lady down the door and I
don't like that either I like
decentralization I don't like
centralization and I definitely don't
like government getting involved with
business because it might start off pure
but eventually there's going to be this
thing known as regulatory capture and
the industries are going to now all of a
sudden pass laws that are going to make
it impossible for the lady down the door
to get into the business because they're
going to be so many rules and
regulations that she just will opt out
completely and now we're inadvertently
taking away the number of child care
providers that exist in the world so so
I know that this is just three thousand
dollars every five years it's not a huge
amount of money but it's just one more
nail in the coffin of what the true goal
should be which is one parent being able
to afford raising an entire family and
the other person stays home and raises
kids that's that's my goal this this is
the opposite of that goal thank you yes
representative
thank you Mr chairman and I I also
um oftentimes uh yearn for the days when
life seemed a bit more ideal but I have
come to realize with a bit more gray
hair that you know oftentimes I have to
deal with the hand that I'm given and we
are dealing with a huge crisis with
child care in this country in our state
we we heard it you know Ad nauseam the
other day right
but the way I look at it is also that
this would be a huge return on
investment for our state we would be
bringing in younger people we would be
supporting the people that go to work
that don't want to work in Target I I
shop at Target it's not a bad place I
don't have a problem with Target per se
but I don't want to see the people that
chose to take care of kids and educate
young children be eroded I mean that is
really an eroding industry and so though
I also don't like to subsidize any
industry unnecessarily but I also know
that we are in a crisis position where
we need to address and that's why I
would agree with Dr Merchant I mean with
uh
representative Merchant that we if we
could at least consider retaining it so
that we can actually figure out a
solution rather than just shut the door
on this group of people that really
depend on us
State the government does subsidize you
know a lot of things in our lives
oftentimes there is not a return on
investment which is of any benefit this
does have a return on investment this
will increase the workforce it will
increase the younger Workforce it will
also to some degree at least the message
will help to increase the number of
people that want to work in New
Hampshire so I I would I would urge us
to try to retain this and work on it
versus just throwing it down the toilet
thank you thank you
representative Nagel thank you am I
supposed to say Thank you Mr chairman
again I'm sorry am I supposed to say
Thank you Mr chairman or here too uh
whatever whatever
thank you Dr Merchant so
um I'm all for spending eight million
dollars if you get eight million dollars
plus in return
um that I think the most compelling
thing that was said was somebody said
that they were losing employees to
Target as you say I think we need to
remember we're just looking this is a
crisis but we're just looking at the tip
of the iceberg in addition to child care
I sit on boards that oversee nine
nursing homes that face the exact same
problems I sit on I own believe it or
not a couple of medical businesses now
that we're about 20 percent uh
underemployed right now
um I I'm on two hospitals that are
totally unemployed all these people are
competing for the same pool of people
with Walmart Target wherever and my
concern is yes we want to spend I think
it was eight roughly eight million
dollars over three years to get us back
to the exact same place we are now I
just don't see this as going to change
the labor force change their
competitiveness at all
I I am leaning towards this retaining
thing
um and and as as representative Leon
said see what this committee comes up
with I just don't personally see this as
a good long-term strategy I think we
need to have a better long-term strategy
that reflects everybody's needs so that
we we hope
you know a lot of people not just this
thank you representative Weber
thank you I I would agree with that and
I but I also I just want to be sure that
we're not closing any doors
um I am also concerned you know this is
a this issue in in Gross rather than the
bill in front of us which we made
certain efforts to send to either the
children and family law committee or the
committee on child care what a concept
but we were told that it was too late
um
we were just told no
which boggles my mind but anyway
um you know this is a priority of
business and industry there's all the
issues of young young people staying in
the state they're the ones who are
looking for the child care and the
housing and all those other things that
bring to bear on the whole big picture
but I'm going to point out that you know
for us to sit here and discuss the huge
issues of why we aren't having one
parent stay home anymore I'm going to
point out that the last time that
happened was in the Eisenhower
Administration when the highest marginal
federal tax rate was over 90 percent
um so things have changed a lot and if I
were in charge of revamping the federal
tax structure I could do a lot because
none of those Yachts would be deductible
and uh but I can't do that and that's
not what we're faced with here today
so
um
I do urge people to overturn oh and
don't get me started on the public
school public money that is now
subsidizing private and religious
schools
because it's exactly the same thing so
um I would I would I would hope that
people would would retain I I think this
is probably not ultimately going to be
the right solution but
um I would love to leave the universe of
possible solutions as wide as possible
for the future
thank you point of order Mr chair yes um
did we have a second
um on this motion and if so
we did have a second yes representative
okay does that mean does that mean we
will vote on it well
they could both
moving party in the second inning party
could it should they choose to do so
um withdraw the motion and the second
but if neither unless that happens then
we we need to vote on it
representative Jeff your hand up a
moment ago or I'm sorry
is there any other discussion on this
motion
okay
um what I would like to do
I'm sorry okay representative Shapiro
again
I I would just like to say that um
my opinions have has changed hearing the
discussion and um
whereas I said I would vote um against
itl and vote um Auto pass I would be in
favor now of retaining the bill and I I
would um
I will try to put my ideology and
philosophy aside and I would ask other
people to try to do the same and um and
just keep an idea in the larger pot
um of things to be considered down the
line because
um
I think there are going to be many
solutions to this problem that are going
to be
an anathema is that the way you
pronounce the word
to various parties
um and um but I hope that that in the
end will not be an excuse for all of us
in the state to just sit by and do
nothing so I would um be in favor of
voting against itl and retaining the
bill in our committee and it will either
come back to our committee or this other
committee on on child care
anyway thank you representative
thank you Mr chair um and and I respect
uh the the everybody's comment so far
and if I thought that you know what
representative Murphy was speaking would
would come to pass
um I think I would be in favor of
retaining but you know I live in
Manchester we are in we're the Nexus of
a housing crisis a mental health crisis
um an opioid crisis and so when I look
at these bills coming in my mind I have
to be able to draw a trajectory because
money is precious I had to be able to
draw that trajectory between where it is
to what the conclusion is going to be
and I think even from the discussion we
have here we're saying yeah we don't
really think this is going to be it but
let's kind of leave that door open but I
think I don't see how this particular
structure could achieve the goal unless
you put a huge amount of money to it and
I think that the special committee on
Child Care can come up with a whole
bunch of other options that aren't
basically necessarily this structure and
I think we're going to have lots of
other options that we're going to be
able to choose from lots of other arrows
that we're going to have in the quiver
but this particular structure I don't
see how it works unless you put a huge
amount of extra money to it and so I'm
going to allow the itl motion to stand
any other discussion
I'm seeing none uh at there's obviously
been the extensive amount of debate on
this as as would be appropriate it's an
important issue I would like to take a
five minute recess and ask the
Republican members to join me in the
back uh office for just a few minutes uh
maybe we can have a bit of a little more
limited discussion on this so give us
five minutes please
[Music]
okay
we've concluded debate at this point on
566.
uh so I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll
uh I'm sorry the motion is remains itl
thank you
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofal
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay
representative uh Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro
no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative Tellez no
and representative Alonso no
and representative McDonald yes
and it is 10 to 10.
okay
motion fails is there another motion
yes
thank you Mr chair I'll move to retain
the bill okay motion's been made to
retain is there a second now second
representative Barbara seconds is there
any discussion on the motion to retain
I think we've all covered it pretty well
okay
um is Clark ready to
not quite but okay I'll go ahead okay
all right
um
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Tellez yes
and representative Lonzo yes
and representative McDonald yes
and a motion is 20 to zero
okay and again this would not go on the
calendar and would not be acted on by
the house and we'll we consider it in
the fall
okay moving on uh House Bill 565
relative to expanding Medicaid to
include certain postpartum Health Care
Services I believe representative Weber
you have an amendment to this
okay that's okay
give two of these to the clerk of one
for me and then I'll send them around is
just with the baby backgrounds
uh
I'll just wait for a minute should I Mr
chair for those to go around sure that's
fine that's fine it's it's not a very
extraordinary Amendment the only thing I
did in the amendment was on the first
and second line of the text of the bill
um I changed the reference
from whatever the act before this was to
the current act which is the
Consolidated Appropriations Act of 2023
rather than the whatever it was Act of
2022 which was what we had before
so that's the that's the sum and
substance that's the sum and substance
it's it it really does
um because section one of the bill was
everything except the enacting Clause I
think anyway the amendment is uh number
zero two nine three h and as I said all
it does is is correct the current
legislation and no further Corrections
were needed in the 42 USC 1396 AE
because it's all still in the same place
it just came from a different Source now
so
um with that I would I would move
Representatives
I'm sorry it's it's late and we're all
tired or it's early and we're all tired
um I would move the adoption of
amendment
20230293h
because it corrects the technicality in
the bill
thank you is there a second
yes representative
uh not a problem thank you
okay any discussion on the amendment
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman I have a question on this um in
looking at the bill there's a section
one that is the title and this is
actually section two
um so it's it has section two
um as opposed to section one so it's
inserting it and correcting it in the
wrong one I'm sorry I just looked at
that when I was trying to do my homework
on the bill and make sure what we had
was correct let me pull up the bill and
see if I can answer that
um
although to provide commentary we did
learn during House Bill 430 last year
that there is some ability to do
something like just change that it'll be
section two and then we can just confirm
that were we to change that wording to
section two of the bill that we would be
all right
yes so when you look at the amendment it
says amend the RSA as inserted by
section one of the bill by replacing it
with the following so what that does um
just technically looking at the bill
that would take lines
it's intended to take lines five through
fifteen and replace them with this
section the problem is that's actually
section two not section one that's one
of those things that was easy to
overlook but we want to make sure that
it is in fact correct
um I think we I think that's something
where we would be able to correct that
or
would it make sense to get that actually
correct
if it's the pleasure of the committee I
would be perfectly happy to go back to
OLS
um
I thought I was handing them a very
simple
Amendment one of the more simple
yesterday afternoon and I thought that
was giving them a great deal of time and
leeway and I was looked at with horror
when I was told that it had to be done
by one o'clock today so
um I'd be more than happy to take it
back and check it with them just to be
sure we've got
our ducks in a row
if that's the pleasure of the committee
because I would love to be able to say
gee this is the sort of thing we can fix
between now and the floor but I'd rather
not have to do it as a floor Amendment
and all the rest of it
so you'd would it be a pleasure
representative that we recess this bill
also or I'll withdraw my motion and if
you would put it on again for next week
that would be grand okay
all right so we will be recessing HB 565
along continuing that along with the
others
oh I'm sorry uh representative Nutter
Upham would you join me in
thank you thank you very much
okay so we will continue that uh to next
week also and this brings us to what I
believe was our last build for
consideration this afternoon which is HP
580. and um representative Merchant you
have a motion
yes I'd like to make a motion to retain
the bill please
okay is there a second
representative McLean
is there any discussion on the motion or
would you like to speak to your motion
okay okay
Mr chair that was seconded by
representative Palmer oh I'm sorry okay
I had you down representative McLean
sorry I'm putting my hand in his in his
representative space representative
Fishman is out of the womb she'll be
right back she got some maternal
responsibilities to fulfill
but but certainly representative
Merchant if you want to speak to you
mostly sure thank you but I I totally
support the intent of this bill
um what I am struggling with though is
some of the concerns that were raised by
some of the folks regarding the bill
and part of this is looking for is the
basic screening
what I'm reading into this is that it
appears to be a reimbursement issue
about the screening Itself by licensed
providers
and I don't think I was per se maybe the
intent of it but I'd like to retain this
to have a little more discussion with
the ophthalmologist and the optometrist
and other people including School nurses
to find out what can and cannot be done
if the school nurses or schools are
actually doing a lot of the screening
maybe this is redundancy so I'd like to
have that kind of a conversation with
the stakeholders and have a little more
robust understanding of what's going on
and bring it back to the committee with
the recommendation
thank you representative uh
representative Nagel
um
my concern with the more the discussion
than the actual bill was
we're really not focusing on school
we're fo and that's why I tried to bring
up the point of points of access
you want to hit a lot of these visual
things from zero to three not five and
Beyond when they're actually in school
and I I was really concerned that the
focus on the bill was getting at school
nurses and this and that and the other
people you really need to be focusing on
well baby checks early Child Development
things like that and I really think
that's what needs to be emphasized in
this bill
representative nego I agree with you 100
the other thing which I brought up
during the testimony this really does
what deals with a subset of the
population which is Medicaid and I like
to look at it more broadly because the
disease itself is unlimited to Medicaid
children so I think we need to look at
it holistically and look at it broadly
so thank you
oh the discussion
representative
this is really just I just wondered um
some of you were parents that had
children in public school systems did
your children get
vision screening I live in the city of
Nashua we have a strong Lions Club I
helped raise money for their machines
and things and and one of my children
who I took yearly to their all of my
children I took yearly to their
physicals daughter number two failed her
eye exam and I'm like well how about
that I'm glad they had the school
screening and took her and she wears
glasses so I just wondered what other
people's experience with their kids were
like really briefly and I agree with a
further look and to get the younger kids
in as we heard from testimony
another discussion
yes sir
I think there was also some
testimony that I read that wasn't
presented the other day from
Ophthalmology and Optometry and they
have concerns about actual inappropriate
referrals so they were work their
concern was worrying that they all of a
sudden we're going to get flooded with
requests to have more comprehensive
exams and they would like to make sure
that that whatever Bill gets crafted
make sure that they that the referrals
are appropriate
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman um I can speak
partly from the point of a parent of
young children
um we actually did the we take care of
all of this stuff through our own
routine
um care it's not something where we're
looking to any screening programs and we
haven't been caught up in these
screening programs but we also
homeschool so um that's that's one where
no we do it's nurse mom
but that's also in in those situations
you you are noticing that if there is
something with where they're looking at
it funny you see that because you're
watching that whole development and it's
not to say that other parents aren't
necessarily looking for that but when
you've taken on that responsibility
you're you're looking at if they're
moving their hand in a particular way
you're you're over analyzing your
children without letting them know so
there is that Focus to it and then also
looking to the issue of specificity and
sensitivity of the diagnostic test
there's that problem if you catch too
many false positives it's worse than no
test so I I think that our attention is
is wonderful for this
okay representative Nagel one of the I
didn't want this to get lost in all the
discussion but there was written
testimony that was given that was not
stated there but this so probably 40
percent of children
do not have a visual screen before age
four and and that was really concerning
and the other thing I want to point out
too is that there are models of care out
there and head injury which is my other
big interest I mean we have most people
doing post-concussive screens are not
doctors they're doing it on young
athletes things like that you can use
that same model to avoid what you're
talking about representative Palm or
these inappropriate referrals these
screens don't need you don't need a lot
of Education to do them
I'm sorry that was me pontificating of
the discussion
yes representative that's right yeah
thank you so uh
a couple things one is I guess when I
originally uh when we were hearing about
it I envisioned the you take your child
to the world child check the medical
assistant has them stand 20 feet away
from the chart on the door and that's
the kind of screening we're talking
about this does include vision screening
of pupils
um and so you know
I don't know if it actually intends to
be more than just someone looks in the
eye with an ophthalmoscope and then
additional vision screening and then I I
also I think what this is tickling for
me is something analogous to the program
I raised yesterday which is there is
universal screening of all babies
um and a whole system set up uh you know
at a national and and state levels to
try to identify hearing loss in children
which is a significant problem you know
early enough that they can be intervened
in a timely fashion and so I agree that
there's some you know if we really want
to make sure that all children are being
screened appropriately then it shouldn't
just be limited to Medicaid
um and so whatever it's raising a lot of
different issues for me
okay thank you
of the discussion
I see no other hands up am I missing
anyone
okay I'll ask the collector column
motion is to retain on high school I'm
sorry
point of order am I yes am I allowed to
vote on this okay thank you
yeah so if you were here when the
question was put so just so everybody
knows until he says the question is you
don't have to be here for all of the all
of the discussion and there will not be
a quiz afterwards
it's just if if we start if if he had
already started and the clerk had
started to call the role you can't then
come in and say oh by the way
thank you
okay I'll ask the clerk to call the wall
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel yes
representative peloso yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Tellez
yes I'm getting there
representative Lonzo yes
representative McDonald yes
motion is 20-0 the vote is 20 to zero
okay thank you I would remind those of
you again who made motions today other
than motions to retain to please write
share committee reports
yes representative land thank you and I
wanted to clarify that on House Bill 91
your Minority Report will be with an itl
recommendation
I think yeah whether it's a majority or
Minority Report please get those done
okay uh yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
in house bill
we elected to recess that until later
date
I would like to work with some of my
peers on this committee
to talk about what we could do to
correct the bill to make it
more palatable to all as many of the
people in the committee as possible so
I'm willing to sort of lead the charge
but I'd like to know if there's anyone
willing to be with me on that charge
representative Leon you would be I'll
meet with you on that one is there
anyone else
anyone else 397 yes it's the needles
representative Nagel
yeah so I have representative Leon
kushman and Nagel yes thank you
any other yes representative Shapiro I
just wanted to make sure if we have the
report to you tomorrow is that okay and
also should we just email it to you oh
yeah you email it to me and I'll forward
it on to the
um the um you know a staff person thank
you
uh yes I may have to edit it it's a bit
long but uh I'll I'll take it
oh really okay that was a mistake
representative knurk wanted everybody to
understand everything did that actually
appear on the calendar what's that did
it appear in the account it was in the
information that we got yesterday from
uh regarding our bills but yeah he was
my role model I apologize okay that's
fine there's no need there's no need to
apologize he he's a wonderful legislator
and a wonderful role model
representative Merchant just the point
of clarification in regards to this had
hot group on rep on House Bill 397.
is it permissible to do this via Zoom or
do we have to schedule it or have a
public hearing with it can we just meet
amongst ourselves via Zoom
but thank you just it's like an ad hoc
group right so it's it is not an
official subcommittee if it was an
official subcommittee appointed by the
chair
which would be preferable but
time is what time is
uh
then it would have to be noticed in the
calendar it would have to be in person
it would have to be here if it is not a
quorum of the committee
or of a subcommittee then you can talk
to whoever you want to and you can meet
wherever you want to there is no
subcommittee so
up to 11 people can meet
under any circumstances that they want
to talk to each other about without
creating
but 11 people can't so 10 or under it's
an informal group in other words so in
saying that if I could meet with
representative Leon Cushman and negle
before we all leave today to look at our
calendars the final time
okay thank you thank you all for doing
that
hey I know I have no other business to
come before us today unless anyone has
any questions I will we will be
adjourned until next Wednesday
you enjoy the rest of your week and have
a good weekend thank you